[Music]
rabbis against Christ so they say yes
it's true that Christ satisfies a lot of
U let's say Old Testament prophecies but
it's not because Christ said and did do
those things it's because the Christians
later on kind of um yeah you know so
they're saying they're taking they're
making up history to
agree yes basically saying you know you
didn't say that and they put in his
mouth and stuff like this so how would
you respond to that well very easy I
would say number
one you have to demonstrate that these
materials are written so far from the
events that they record so they can get
away with making up sayings of Jesus
because if they're written early on in
front of eye and ear Witnesses who are
still alive in the thousands how do they
get away with this lie and convince
people to follow the
lie that's a fantastic answer yeah
that's what I would say because the
argument is well they're just making up
stories to make Jesus fit the Old
Testament say okay hold
on if we go with the evidence that these
writings are early they're written
within the first two generations of the
eyewitnesses some of these writings are
early as 4950 ad there're still
thousands of witnesses alive who saw
Jesus both friendly and
hostile how do they get away with the
lie and convince people who are still
alive where eyewitnesses to believe this
lie yeah and some here I'll give you
another example yeah if we go with the
dating of Matthew Mark Luke and acts as
being in the early 60s because if we go
with the time given by Luke and acts
Paul is still under house arrest so that
means he Luke and acts was written
around 62 ad the reason why we say that
remember the session I did I think you
were the one I answered the question for
yeah Luke mentions the death of James
the brother of John by Herod he men
mentions the death of Steven but Peter
and James the so-called Lord's brother
and Paul which are prominent in the book
of Acts they were martyred James was
martyred 62 ad Peter and Paul around
6460 ad and the temple was destroyed 70
AD all of which is prominent Luke and
acts but Luke doesn't mention any of
that in other words if Luke does mention
Steven's death and James death and he's
writing after Paul had been martyred and
Peter had been martyred and James had
been martyred and Jerusalem was
destroyed he would have mentioned those
events right yeah why does he end with
Paul still in house arrest awaiting
trial before Caesar why doesn't he tell
us what happened afterwards he leaves us
in suspense if you read acts 28 Paul is
still in house arrest he's given freedom
to have people visit him so he's
preaching the gospel but we're not given
the climax of the story the climax is
he's going to meet Caesar and he's going
to preach the gospel to him well what
happened doesn't tell us why does he on
on that Cliffhanger because it hadn't
happened why does he mention that James
the so-called brother of the Lord was
martyred in 62 ad 62 ad when he was
thrown off the Pinnacle of the temple
and when he landed they clubbed and
stoned him because it hadn't happened
why didn't he mention Peter was
crucified in Rome because it hadn't
happened why didn't he mention Jerusalem
was destroyed it didn't happen so if
these events didn't happen Luke doesn't
mention them well if James was martyred
62 ad that means Luke finished acts
right around 62 ad
right but Luke is before acts that means
Luke would have been written late 50s
early 60s right y but then they tell me
Matthew's before Luke that means
Matthew's in the 50s but then they tell
me Mark is before Matthew that means
Mark is in the
40s see how how early yeah another
indication that Mark is early are you
ready another indication Mark is early
when Matthew and Luke mention the high
priest they say the high priest caiaphus
that means they're writing early enough
but not so early where they cannot
mention who the high priest is because
they're writing at a time he's no longer
the high priest so they got to tell you
who it is it's like today if I say hey
you see what the president did in in
Jerusalem you know what I'm talking
about right if I'm an
America Biden yeah but what if I write
40 years from now and say Hey you see
what the president did when Israel
attacked Gaza what president yeah I have
to then be specific
right I would have to say President
Biden right yeah but in Mark if you read
Mark 14 he doesn't tell you who the high
priest was he says the high priest
condemned him but doesn't give his
name why because he was close because
he's writing close enough where they
knew who the high priest was Kus because
we know from extra biblical sources
caiaphus was the high priest from 18 to
ad for Mark to Simply say the high
priest and not mention his name means
he's writing so close to these events
that people already know who the high
priest is but later on Matthew Mark
Matthew Luke after to then specify was
caiaphus yeah okay so all of this shows
that Matthew Mark Luke and John are
written
40s right
50s early
60s okay if it's Mark is written in the
40s that's less than 10 years of Jesus
resurrection Matthew in the 50s less
than 20 years there are still thousands
of eyewitnesses enemies and friends who
would expose or confirm what these
gospels are saying yeah so if they're
lying how did they get away with it yeah
how do they convince thousands of Jews
and pagans to start work worshipping
Jesus the
Jew what happened no no it's a great
response and I guess there are some
passages as well that you cannot uh even
make up like you know that the gospel
will go to the whole Nations like you
know how do yeah and another one I want
to give you okay if they're
lying and they're written that early
right because the evidence shows they're
written early that means the Sanhedrin
is still around the San right because it
would have been destroyed between 6673
AD right yeah how did they get away with
saying that it was two members of the
San hendr Joseph arthea and
Nicodemus that actually were supportive
of Jesus and bury Jesus in Joseph's tomb
if they're lying and they're making up
the name Joseph armea how did they get
away with it
yeah because go Joseph would be like
dude you're putting me in trouble what
you do or if there was no Joseph say hey
liar the San is still here we don't know
any Joseph or Nicodemus right now
Nicodemus mentioned by John but Matthew
Mark and Luke mentioned Joseph Aria a
prominent member of the Sanhedrin how if
the Sanhedrin was still alive and
functioning when they write the gospels
and in shows they were and there was no
Joseph how did they get away with that
lie and then another point I want you to
remember another Point Matthew 28 11-15
state that when they discovered watch
this Matthew 28 11:15 when they
discovered that the tum was empty the
sanedrin the ruling Authority told the
Roman guards they paid them off saying
tell people that when you were asleep
the disciples came and stole the body
yeah okay now watch why this is
important I'll use the new Indian
version watch here and then because look
what look what Matthew says now watch
this detail these are details that by
the illumination of the Holy Spirit you
got a pay attention to Guys these are
the details that the Holy Spirit puts
there to confirm Beyond any Ral doubt
your gospels are historically accurate
don't doubt them our Lord Is Alive okay
now here are the details that the spirit
has put there for us to discover by his
power watch here Matthew 28
11-15 while the woman were on their way
some of the guards went into the City
and reported to the chief priests
everything that had happened when the
chief priest had met with the
elders and devised a plan they gave the
soldiers a large sum of money telling
them you are to say his disciples came
during the night and stole them away
while we were asleep if this report gets
to the
governor we will satisfy him keep you
out of trouble because it was capital
punishment if a soldier failed at his
duty he would be
killed right so they're saying don't be
afraid we'll tell the governor we put
you up to it so it don't kill you now
watch what Matthew says so they the
soldiers took the money and did as they
were instructed and this St story has
been widely circulated among the Jews to
this very day very day of
what that he's
writing but wait how did Matthew get
away with it if he was lying about this
story yeah to this very day the rumor is
the disciples stole the body well
Matthew you're making up stories well if
he did how did he get away with this so
someone said you're lying Matthew no one
spread that story because this story
affirms two things the tomb was empty
the body was gone exactly yeah because
they have to tell the people well they
stole the body what does that mean there
was no body of Jesus it was gone the
tomb was empty they explain it as the
disciples stealing the body that's
number two in other words this not only
shows
that the tomb was empty the body of
Christ was gone it also shows that even
Jesus's enemies acknowledge the tomb was
empty the body was gone and Matthew's
writing early enough because he says
this story still circulates to his day
how did he get away with this if he's
lying well he's not lying that's why he
got away with it but more importantly if
they're asleep how did they know who
stole the
body because it says Tell them while
you're asleep the disciples stole the
body well if you're asleep how do you
know who stole
it you're
sleeping right yeah you're asleep so who
who how do you know they stole it you're
asleep man you got to be awake to know
that right but then how do you explain
that none of the
disciples caved in and
denied the resurrection but all of them
were willing to be killed for saying no
he's alive he's not
dead so now that's destroy what the Jews
say or anyone else says oh they just
made up the stories well how did they
get away with it so you would say if if
you can prove that they have written
early basically destroy the argument
it's like they just fighting what every
no no that's say that's your arguments
are pathetic because you can't make up
stories if you're writing within
thousands of eyewitnesses who are not
just friendly but enemies weding waiting
to destroy your faith and then how do
you explain thousands of Jews and Greeks
worshiping Jesus the Jew Greeks
worshiping a Jew not even someone who's
Greek and abandoning the worship of
their gods and goddesses and being
killed for it how do you explain that
because the conversion of Jews and
Gentiles happened in Mass numbers
thousands within 20 years how do we know
within 20 years because when Paul is
writing to Christians at Corinth and in
1 Corinthians he's writing around 55 ad
and there there are Gentiles who are
worshiping Jesus as God who no longer
worshiping the pagan gods and he's
writing 55 ad and yet these people were
already converted and baptized before he
wrote to them what's leading these
Greeks to embrace Jesus the Jew less
than 10 20 years of his death if he
wasn't raised alive convincing them he's
no mere man he's God In the Flesh